in the middle of the ocean he's an  island where animals rule is there  anything you wouldn't eat until the day  they got an unexpected visitor what do  you say we help him out now what is  going on what hey Angelo this is the  exterminator you call for your rat  problem accounts looking a little thin  no one gets paid into what needs to get  done it gets done nope that's not the  rules no money no honey  hello hey hi didn't want to wait until  tomorrow so I grabbed the next plane out  good good congratulations hora I mean  isn't it a little early in a year to go  fishing seeking the facts was hardly  fishing mr. Skiles okay then here's the  most important fact there's only two  people who know what happened in the  cockpit that day and I'm one of them and  we appreciate your perspective why do  you even think we're here today